welcome to code tech and tutorials if
you're new here
please subscribe and don't forget to
like this is my pc
i've been using for about the last five
years and
the old motherboard finally gave out so
i had to do some upgrades and this
is what all these clips are from is me
doing the upgrade
i've sped it up quite a bit because
there is a lot of video
but basically what i do here is well
here i'm removing the old board and you
can see it is
an h11 well let's see h
110 m gigabyte board
now this thing is fine really just
something glitched out
on me after a while and kept crashing
and i seem to figured out it was coming
from the motherboard so i went ahead and
got a new motherboard
and this time i got a gaming quality one
through asus you can see down there here
i am removing the
sink from the old one and this was all
quite a pain to do
but i've done this sort of thing a ton
throughout my life and i love doing this
sort of thing so
i wanted to share with you guys some of
this
interesting stuff
there's the old cpu now something
interesting happened here i thought
that i could use the same cpu so that
one you see in the video right
now is in high 7700k and it does slot
correctly into this new motherboard
but this new board wants 8 000 or 9000
series
chips so ultimately this didn't end up
booting although it fits so
i went through a lot of stuff here that
i didn't need to go through because i
had to change out the cpu anyway but i
did find out a few things
so the main thing is well this little
micro atx
board here doesn't
fit this heatsink this whole bracket
around it and everything it keeps
hitting all these heatsinks on the side
of this motherboard so i was able to
like
squeeze it in there and really use some
tricks to do all that but
i found out eventually that this wasn't
really a feasible option
i had to remove all these side brackets
to even get it to fit and be able to
latch
and found out there is m2 slots on the
front and back of this motherboard so
that's super cool
it's a nice option to have
but here i am taking off yet another
side bracket i hope you guys enjoy this
sort of video i know it's way different
from the other stuff i do here but it's
something i really enjoy and it's kind
of where i got my roots i used to build
computers
all the time and toy with them and
tinker with them and tinker with
electronics a ton
when i was growing up and when i
discovered computers it was a whole new
world of tinkering that i've been into
for a long time so
yeah you can see i'm just kind of it
looks like i'm just manhandling things
and that's because i've done this so
many times that i'm not really afraid of
anything
um
yeah so yeah i got it all this heatsink
all mounted here
go ahead and pop my hard drive back in
here
i love this case you can just do so much
with it
and it seems to fit everything for a
micro atx case
it's like a little gaming box a little
power box
this ended up being a several day
process like after this day and figuring
out that the cpu didn't work
i had to come back at it another day
after
swapping out cpus i had to order a new
cpu sold the old one
and ended up being a pretty even trade
and then i also had to get a new
heatsink
this heatsink wasn't going to work in
the long run
but i wanted to see if it would at least
boot with this processor
there's only four mounting screws on
these small
itx motherboards one on each corner
you've got to have a magnetic
screwdriver for this sort of process
otherwise you're going to drop screws
all over your case
getting these little screws in there is
more difficult than it seems
you really have to carefully line it up
if you drop the screw it goes down in
the case somewhere and that's no fun to
fish it out
so i was being super careful there and
didn't drop any but i have done it
before
and now i'm just plugging in all these
cables into their proper spots
some of which aren't immediately evident
this motherboard i actually got from an
ebay auction it was a pretty good deal
for what it was
but it didn't come with any extra parts
including the manual
luckily though that's all online so the
things that weren't labeled on the
motherboard
i was able to just look up
but for the most part it was pretty
standard stuff and i was able to plug in
all the main rails
the thing about pushing these cables in
on this motherboard
is there's only four mounting screws so
you gotta be real careful
about not pushing too hard and bowing
the motherboard
so there i was looking at all where
everything lines up
to plug in all these cables for the
front panel and everything
i only do some minimum wire management
here not really too concerned this is
just to see if it boots really
which as you already know because i've
already said it doesn't end up booting
it just flashes with a cpu error code
so another nice thing about this new
motherboard
is it has error codes right on the board
so if it doesn't boot you don't get a
screen
you can at least look at the flashing
codes reference them in the manual
if you need to basically it had a cpu
error here eventually which i will show
soon as i get all these cables plugged
in
i know riveting stuff watching a guy
plug in cables
what i was doing off screen here that
you can't really tell is i was lining up
all of these little pins
to be a nice solid block that matches
the block they fit into on the
motherboard
this is something i like to do but i
don't actually see many people do it
then after that i used thermal tape
to make a solid block that can just be
pulled in and out as a single instance
of a cable rather than a bunch of
in-piece ones
and i just nipped the tape there that
was extra
gotta plug in all my sata cables there
are four hard drives in this machine
as you might know i do this youtube
stuff and it ends up taking a lot of
recording
space yeah anyway i got distracted there
gtx 1080 founders edition this is a
pretty old car at this point
but as you can see in this micro etx
case
and with these motherboards there's a
perfect spot
for the gpu a full-size gpu
and here i went ahead and powered it on
and it would just immediately shut off
so here's a look at the flashing code
happened super quick there you couldn't
really see it but it basically flashed
bad cpu
and now we're on to a new day here
i went ahead and ordered a
new heat sink that was a water cooler
now this
had to happen basically because i
couldn't fit any traditional air
flow heat sink on there as you saw
before
so i ordered this
up here brand and it comes with a 240
millimeter
thermal thing radiator thermal thing
and the fans are over on the right so
what i was doing here is i was basically
pre-planning
and seeing how i had to mount it now i
kind of figured out
that these tubes and the wires in the
computer and the way everything flows
there was really only one way it would
fit and it was in this direction i
believe so i had to make sure all the
screw holes would line up because i did
have to mount it still
and i still had to put the fans on as
well but these cords and stuff were
blocking and actually this front fan
right here
was blocking so there was no way this
radiator was going to fit in here with
this fan in
oddly enough i don't get my head in the
way i didn't realize i was doing that
so i had to remove this fan it was
really difficult as you can see i
couldn't get a screwdriver down there
because the way it opens
but i was able to use the old uh crank
technique
with a pair of pliers and something else
yeah interesting angle i had no idea i
was recording like that
but yeah this was actually really
difficult to get this fan out because of
how little space there was to work with
these screws
but i did eventually get it pull it out
of there i really don't want to remove
the front fan but
i didn't see any other option i couldn't
flip this around the other way it would
hit the heat sinks
on the motherboard i think but that way
it worked fine
so with that all planned i decided okay
let's go ahead and get these fans
mounted on here and then we'll get the
whole thing mounted on the case
so i'm mounting these fans that came
with it
and i know everybody's probably going to
say the same thing in the comments you
should never use an electric
screwdriver on computers and i'm aware
of that but uh
um remember i'm a professional
i did not mess up any of the screws
actually i don't you know i don't like
fully torque it with the
electric screwdriver of course not but
when it's like a really long
job see as you can see i'm custom
tightening it with my hand
i was just using that power screwdriver
to get it initially set
into a loose state and then i would
manually tighten them with my hand
later because if you just use the uh
the power drill the whole time you'll
strip the screws out so you don't want
to do that typically it's best just not
to use them at all but
i'm so used to this that i feel pretty
comfortable using one and i don't feel
i'm going to mess up anything but
basically you can only
initiate all the uh the screws with them
you don't want to tighten with them it's
the point even at the lowest setting
so i went ahead and started mounting the
radiator this was a real pain to do
actually because i had to like hold it
from the back while screwing in the
first two were the hardest
but once i got a couple of corner ones
started the rest were already lined up
so i could kind of keep going
but it was interesting because i had to
push from the back of the radiator a lot
and
you know push right on the corners
but it took a total of eight screws to
get this radiator mounted and with those
fans on the back
already set it's pretty much in a state
where it's ready to get put on the
motherboard
but this got a little tricky here
i forget what was going on i think i was
trying to get that under bracket set
correctly the bracket
that was putting on earlier underneath
the motherboard
yeah i think i just have to turn the cam
off as you can see i got it set
and started screwing all these in you
want to cross thread
and i was a little worried there's not
going to be space for
the ram there and it's pretty tight
there's just barely space space for the
ram
i was pretty nervous about the whole
thing trying to figure out what to do
ultimately it did rub across the cables
but it wasn't so significant that i
thought it was going to hurt anything so
i just left it
and it's pretty packed in there as you
can see i know wobbly video
sped up video but that that's how she
is right now and i just wanted to see if
it booted and i did get at the boot on
first try which is always a great
success and you can see all the specs
there
there we go we got to the
the bios so that's always what you want
on the first boot
is just being able to get to the bios is
a great success so it looks like
everything is keeping cool
and everything seems to be functioning i
don't see any
problems here so at this point i think i
just boot to my old windows
which it doesn't like at first i have to
do a quick repair
uh yeah i forget what happened here but
yeah i just rebooted i didn't even do
the repair
and it did boot up and have to find all
my new devices and all that stuff but
it booted right up into windows new
motherboard new cpu
well do i love this case i'm glad i
could keep it i was worried i would have
to swap it out
but i'm gonna keep using the corsair
250d
they're really hard to find now you
can't buy them new anymore
and that's the video special shout out
to my patrons
on patreon
i'll see you guys in the next video
peace out